foreign
I don't know where I'm going to be
that's why Allah
said no one
loves
to establish a proof If I remember the
word of the Hadith
excuse me
do nothing I put us in this life if you
ask fluid and everything
and of course Allah also wants to
implements other names of attributes
also we have to understand you know
sometimes people
generally speaking
what happens outside
sometimes people don't know that we have
a soul
either you can control it it will
control you and say to effective
and the sword is like a baby
so I remember
anyone try to make anything to not use
yeah see so this argument now for
example someone must say you know it was
good for Allah to create a certain way
and put Uganda
in this life test it first to know what
I did so who's gonna who now what
happened Allah
Allah is the old wives are his creation
we don't dictate Allah how we should
create
like another question that people ask
once I was speaking a guy as a team uh
you're good you know worship Him you say
yeah but he never asked me yeah
positive this question doesn't make any
sense why because before you if if you
were allowed to ask you if we create you
he has to create you first in order to
ask you
so it's called seventh street is a
question that you create the first part
of the question contradict the the other
part for for the second part contradict
the First contradict the first part it
doesn't make any sense so one of those
questions especially what you ask but
you don't know you just repeating it but
Allah he creates us it wasn't his life
as a human being with some reason okay
there's a creation Almighty I can't see
the management of the manifestation for
this actually
with power his Mercy is anger so not as
a servant of his and he's my Lord what
is upon me towards him
when you go to school
you don't understand you're not gonna
start focusing on the why the platform
is downstairs downstairs
the foolish man will do that imagine you
go to school and I go to school and the
whole year people study and me what I'm
doing uh principle why did the bathroom
downstairs
foreign
reason you're here not to question these
things how do we do with you you're here
study likewise we're here to for a
purpose it's a test do we know the test
yes so what's up on me did the creator
who create everything told us how to
pass the test the the test yes so I have
to do it makes sense
yeah and I was to bring it back to the
principles okay
sometimes maybe you go to a GP and the
Jeep will give you a mitigation and it
will tell you to put it somewhere in a
place like behind this yeah there's
something
behind you but you think
and you know your knowledge concerning
medicine is very tiny in comparison to
his knowledge correct so logic dictates
you think you know what man knowledge
about medicine it's very little tiny it
doesn't make any sense for me to
criticize his decision what about us as
a human beings I want knowledge our
wisdom is nothing in comparison to the
wisdom Allah
we should submit to him no big change to
him
success
I have other questions
you know you said many other religions
or something yeah
you were 16 yeah
we don't have long life
study
out of versions yeah that's why the old
wise Creator Allah when you create the
creation and when he sent down the Quran
or before that when you create a secret
actually the tools
Universal choose every human being
naturally you know you don't study
nothing actually you know
yeah
exists at the same time yeah okay at
also you know there's something if I'm
holding so if I'm looking for my camera
so
[Music]
foreign
you're with me yeah it's not my
necessity so would you have these
Universal tools that Allah creates us
with when you compare any religion Islam
goes in line with it
look out yeah you know when you look to
this creation it's Universal the
universe and you read Allah describing
something it makes sense that Allah is
the creator of this tremendous beautiful
creation Allah describe yourself
a semi or old hearing al-jabbar the
compeller AL Hayes
in charge of everything a summit
self-sufficient is not in need of
nothing everyone's in need of it okay
everything is
indeed powerful you know
more generous and as is the almighty so
how Allah
iPhones
oh the one who make iPhone is completely
paralyzed
because in order to create something you
need the power you need the knowledge
and so on so
what we say to you that we need to Islam
about describe yourself likewise
Mohammed I saw some teaching you know I
always mentioned when you Islamic
registration staff came to preserve five
things
these five things a step gets preserve
if we do preserve it we will have a
happy Society a good a good site which
is the first Islam came to preserve
solution yeah what does that mean it
means that it is that
pollution Worship in one code alone is
very important that's why paganism
politicism is forbidden why because we
need a worship in the poor God stop
following your own desires
intellects
the first thing okay secondly intellect
that one Islam alcohol and drugs is
forbidden
birthday is
that's why you need to hold it in case
we have wealth that's why interest and
Company is forbidden
hopefully Islam can preserve lineage
family marriage that's what fornication
adultery is forbidden lastly is a lie
that's why committing suicide is harming
yourself is forbidden these five things
system came to preserve
there is a capital punishment anyone
tried to break it why because we need to
bring this Universal for this uh because
Universal necessity we will corrupt our
society
opposite Sun okay
likewise
it's interesting likewise interests
foreign
they come from broken houses
I don't know their parents generally
speaking of course there is deception
yeah
to preserve it's very hard with us at
our code and doesn't believe and drugs
because of the great evil really
it's fine
I'm sorry
Ramada
time
so it goes back to
thank you
Allah and this is the outcome foreign
[Music]
foreign
I believe I was born in the wrong body I
should be harmless are you going to help
me to cover up
what are you gonna think about me
it's not normal but why they're
supporting it because already our human
nature
that is
them that's what it is
no Buddhism no Sikhism
Christianity
out there
educate
all the things he become Muslim because
he says I'm a Muslim unit
and
secret sites in contact with him the
elite at the top ones and they start
offering crazy things and he said I knew
step only salvation
this is
why I become Muslim Muslim is something
to your creator
take you back our man this is
existed 1 400 years
who couldn't read and write actually we
never went to University
is a perfect way of life
on the other hand we have this
politicians
studied in the best universities around
the world yet they come over it was a
problem
because that man was aficion
at Allah knows about us
that's fun
Alexa yeah
and everyone has told me to
situation yeah
so God creates Mr family but he's gonna
punish him for the most doesn't make any
sense that's why Islam where is
[Applause]
All Mankind Believers or non-believers
so
that's the point here the point there is
when you come to to
laugh Allah like I said the way it's
just us
whatever you believe what do you buy
that you can choose
Allah
so likewise
he mentioned many prophecies
right now he said we'll come outside
with interest and by the way let me go
back to the fight things which instead
and to watch I guess the other thing is
destroyed us hardcore and so on there is
some people do benefit from these spices
yeah that are for example in nature
that's one major time those are very hot
guess what Allah
other religion that Allah another verse
Allah
you can see that right now black was the
problem interest he said it will come a
time when it just become widespread
all right now by default if you open the
bank account
what happened to you
you involved with interest yeah your
money has been used even your money's
been used yeah and I propose Muhammad
said it will become white threat even if
the evolved directly
right now
let me ask this question
imagine
if you wake up in the morning and you
say fire is
and you try your best to self yourself
[Music]
other side but I never gave your life
that's why you will say we have to wash
Allah with Allah Allah our worship we
are in need
his love
but he turns away from it arrogantly
then early will take our revenge in the
premium
mankind
here with Dave judgments the meaning of
the verse I prepare you so for the day
of judgments how many people left the
houses
you know how many people are in the car
which is into music drop dead have you
have you seen the wrap of America South
Africa who died while he was singing
the South African rapper
while he was having a concert
he was singing drop dead
you never expected something in his life
stories
[Music]
imagine the day for sleep to your house
tonight
in the middle of nowhere how are you
gonna feel
momentum
become very excited why because
foreign
the whole world
I give it to you would you sacrifice it
today to serve yourself in the
punishment to say yes for my Lord
says
but this that's why ghost is
arrogance because if I saved your life
you will thank me thank you Allah
I know you stand in the right in front
of me I'm speaking to you right now
regardless how many people
theories that you have in China in
Algeria I want to listen to I don't have
time I would not even entertain the
arguments
so far
you have any questions
are you gonna sleep tomorrow
well I forget of course but you know
there's nothing for guaranteed
it's done
what I'm saying because but yes let me
give you examples
you love your mother with your heart
you love your mother
told us
[Music]
to yourself
people that
yeah
you know what we say to you
about
yeah like you want to do yourself
because when you die and they put in the
grave your mother will not come to even
spend one night for this equipment
you know what everyone will leave
and they will turn away from you you'll
be by yourself so be honest with
yourself
you died today
and you stand before you create a lot
and Allah will ask you you know if there
is true
you know how many times we've been doing
this for the last 10 years or something
we have many people like you came and
they say
and this question on us when I'm asking
someone
you've seen it you know what's true
foreign
are you a good person abandon your
parents you remember you go to your
neighbors but you abandon your parents
a good person but remember you're doing
something good taking care of the
neighbor are you missing parents
your parents before likewise priorities
Allah
Allah creates you and it creates your
parents
the associate battles with him but I
forgive less than that to whom he will
and when you become Muslim all this is
Forgiven alhamdulillah
physically
especially because that perfect way of
life
even the doctor how many doctors advised
with fasting
are also stopped up your heart to more
than four people
what's that so what we say to you bro we
make sense we straight to you of course
I cannot accept everything step by step
and you eat the whole cake what will
happen to you
in order for future
cake
step by step the first thing is is apart
read this Bible please once
foreign
is a miracle remember a liar he will try
to utilize anything to justify and back
up his claim correct I'm a liar because
you know the worst liar someone claimed
to the prophet of the whole mighty
okay
he said no
what has happened
what Allah
anymore
of Allah
you commanding me as a message of Allah
if he was a liar
if I'm a liar what I do I would try to
see my friend
foreign
[Music]
yes
how many years
foreign
Before Time
by Imagine The Prayer the prayer will be
grateful to be
when you get many rewards and many
things been wiped away and how many
people committed suicide you know
suicide is on the high right now it's
crazy you know it's
decline it's praise God all right
because when you have when you empty
from here
nothing fulfilled the empty success
instead and many people think when you
commit suicide it's the end so that's
the beginning
foreign
so
someone who's easy
kill himself
he said for someone stupid
foreign
people
another one is worth itself it's not a
hater okay and he was known to be I
belonged to a political party
yes where is everyone good yeah and he
was known to be very evil for his death
so even though he had uh
[Music]
foreign
today
really
huh
but what I'll say to you like I said you
don't have enough time for all the
religions but I can give you a book
shall I read it
maybe when I come back next week
attack I think
alhamdulillah
I have two brothers with me here one of
them alhamdulillah spoke to him and he
was recorded and this brother came a
week before before him a week and he
became Muslim alhamdulillah so what was
your background before
um
Christian or agnostic atheist agnostic
Muslim so how do you know how you found
about Islam
friends
answered some questions
you've been with him for two weeks now
uh yeah a week and a half two years how
are you feeling good good is a big
blessing you know I'm not to give you
ahead but I wasn't there I had to go to
pick up my daughters from the school
yeah because look what are you located
we came around four o'clock I think
what about your family are they the
Christians well my mom like believed in
God but it's not but she's not like she
has a photo yeah man you just live with
your mom yeah man you know what she see
you can give her about your action
you know because you know even she's not
even your mother she's not a Believer
but you have to be good you have to take
care of her because when you show her
your actions how you respect her more
you know take care of her she over spend
time with her then you know she'll be
okay why must my son my son has changed
of course through Islam because Islam
pays great attention to and importance
to be good to your parents and I'm very
happy for you I'll be coming as for you
last week alhamdulillah aike I spoke to
him and now he's going to take shadesh
Allah I'm gonna record it I'm doing that
so uh I'm gonna say the shadow
and he's after me okay
Allah Allah
Allah in English I bear witness I bear
witness there's nothing there's nothing
worthy of worship
in truth
except Allah accept Allah and that their
Witness
foreign
and your story is amazing too
so these two brothers
you go same school
so he became Muslim way before him
alhamdulillah
[Music]
so you said your mother she's a Somalian
yeah and your father is Austrian
Austrian so you you live with the above
them no my dad works in Austria and
Germany okay you shall I give him damage
even you try to give down to your mommy
to come back to Islam
you know why she left Islam
may I will pray to Allah bring her back
to Islam you know I mean sometimes
people leave Islam because
the way they were treated by some
Muslims
or sometimes what happened for example
some people think from Islam to force
your daughter or your son to get married
to someone they don't like yourself from
Islam
for Islam and love Islam gives the
option for the daughter to get married
to whatever she wants likewise for the
son so sometimes what happened some
Muslims mix up Islam with culture
and there is there's no problem with
culture as long as an oppose the Islamic
teaching you know so inshallah you can
bring about Islam but of course Islam is
based upon knowledge you have to study
alhamdulillah you have to learn and now
both you have to understand not just you
or us you know Satan when he see you
start practicing Islam and you are on
the right path he will try his best to
misguide you
so you have to be patient it's not about
the start to be honest it's about the
end alhamdulillah before both of you to
become Muslim no doubt but you have to
be strong and and one of the means one
of the ways to be to stay strong upon
Islam to have good friends around you
you have to have good friends around you
you know and uh may Allah bless you my
brothers
day after so it's going to be the first
Ramadan have you a lot fast before
no I don't know it's gonna be easy it's
easier it's good for us it's a way of
worship no doubt and it's good for your
heart also the the benefits of fasting
that is soften your hearts towards the
poor people
of course you know you feel sorry for
the poor people but imagine you are
fasting for eight hours or nine hours so
your heart become more softened towards
what those who've been
doesn't
eaten for two days or something that's
why Ramadan we always give charity
outside Ramadan likewise but in Ramadan
it's more you know alhamdulillah any
questions no no bless you my brothers
hopefully I'll see you again inshallah
okay